[Música]
alexéi navalni fue enviado a un hospital
penitenciario tras presentar
complicaciones en su salud
el líder opositor ruso completa ya tres
semanas en huelga de hambre la comunidad
internacional advirtió al gobierno ruso
que habría consecuencias sin abalde y
muere en prisión
sus seguidores se preparan para una
serie de protestas que las autoridades
han calificado como ilegales
tensión en el fútbol europeo la uefa
aseguró que vetará a los jugadores que
participen de la superliga un nuevo
torneo paralelo creado por dos equipos
con el objetivo de aumentar los ingresos
que actualmente se reciben en las
competencias europeas un proyecto
calificado por las autoridades de la
fifa como separatista
el ingeniero completó su exitoso vuelo
en marte el pequeño helicóptero de la
nasa y su historia al ser el primer
objeto construido por el ser humano debí
volar de manera controlada en otro
planeta una hazaña comparada por la nasa
con el logro de los hermanos wright
pioneros de la aviación
bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo de
france 24 los saluda andrés meza muñoz
el opositor ruso alexéi navalni quien se
encuentra en huelga de hambre desde
finales de marzo fue trasladado a un
hospital para reclusos debido a su
delicado estado de salud según expertos
médicos que han intentado verlos sin
éxito naval cne enfrenta posibilidades
de fallo renal y hasta de paro cardíaco
eso por esto que sus partidarios están
convocando protestas masivas para el
próximo 21 de abril
el kremlin rechazó el llamado a
manifestaciones y la policía lanzó
advertencias a quienes asistan la
comunidad internacional advirtió al
gobierno ruso que habrá consecuencias
sin aval ni moore en la cárcel
el equipo de médicos de alexéi navalni
ha recurrido a twitter para arremeter
contra los funcionarios de las prisiones
rusas por impedirles ver a su paciente
estuvimos dos horas aquí todo el mundo
entiende que alexéi navalni está en un
estado grave y crítico
desafortunadamente no se nos permite
verlo sus doctores dicen que navalny
podría morir en cualquier momento ya que
los resultados de sus pruebas médicas
muestran que tiene insuficiencia renal y
los niveles de potasio peligrosamente
altos el servicio penitenciario trasladó
al opositor a un hospital para reclusos
actualmente el estado de salud de nava
ni se evalúa como un satisfactorio es
examinado por un médico general todos
los días con el consentimiento del
paciente se prescribió una terapia
vitamínica navalny comenzó una huelga de
hambre hace tres semanas después de que
las autoridades penitenciarias se
negaron a permitirle ver a un médico
privado aseguran que estas imágenes que
lo muestran en un dormitorio de la
prisión en marzo sirven como prueba pero
éstas no pueden ser verificadas
independientemente naval ni fue
encarcelado en febrero tras regresar de
alemania donde fue tratado por un
envenenamiento del que culpa al kremlin
horas después de un discurso a la nación
del presidente putin los partidarios más
cercanos al opositor están convocando
protestas nacionales para el miércoles
pero desde el kremlin calificaron la
convocatoria como provocador a la
policía rusa advirtió que no se
permitirá ninguna desestabilización que
las protestas se considerarán ilegales y
que tomarán todas las medidas necesarias
para dispersarlas
la unión europea hace responsable a
rusia por la salud del líder opositor
alexéi navalni así lo anunció el jefe de
la diplomacia europea de yuste por el en
una reunión virtual de cancilleres del
bloque sin embargo por ahora no se
planea imponer más sanciones contra
rusia pese al pedido de ucrania debido a
la presencia de tropas rusas en la
frontera entre ambos países unos 150.000
soldados según denunció la unión europea
de otra parte el bloque emitió un
segundo paquete de sanciones contra
mianmar dirigidas a 10 funcionarios de
la junta militar golpista
nuestra corresponsal estaría herrera con
la información
las tensas relaciones entre la unión
europea y rusia- siguen copando las
preocupaciones de la política exterior
europea los cancilleres europeos
reunidos en videoconferencia han
mostrado su enorme preocupación por la
situación del líder opositor alexéi
navalni que a pesar de que hayas podido
ser enviado a un hospital de presos se
ha pedido al gobierno ruso que se le
ofrezca apoyo del personal sanitario de
su confianza tal y como lleva pidiendo
desde hace días el líder opositor
prestar no es la única preocupación que
tiene ahora mismo la unión europea con
respecto a rusia también sobre la
movilización de tropas en la frontera
entre ucrania y rusia según el jefe de
la diplomacia europea ya hay 150.000
tropas movilizadas en esta región lo que
aumenta enormemente la tensión por ello
han pedido a moscú que desde esta
movilización de tropas la mayor de la
historia de la región aún así se
descartan por el momento nuevas
sanciones a rusia aunque sí que se han
aplicado nueva sanción
a 10 altos cargos militares de myanmar
relacionados con el reciente golpe de
estado en el país por otra parte el jefe
de la diplomacia europea sí que se ha
mostrado esperanzado por los avances que
está viendo en viena con relación al
pacto nuclear con irán el jefe de la
diplomacia europea se ha mostrado
esperanzado y que está viendo
suficientes progresos con respecto a
eeuu y que pueda volver de nuevo al
acuerdo nuclear
hay tensión en el fútbol europeo a raíz
de la decisión de 12 clubes de crear su
propio torneo llamado superliga y que ha
causado el rechazo de las autoridades de
este deporte
la uefa calificó a este proyecto como
una vergüenza y un escupitajo en la cara
para los amantes del fútbol su
presidente aseguró que los jugadores que
se unan a él serán vetados de
competiciones como la copa del mundo y
la eurocopa la situación se convierte en
una batalla por el control de los juegos
en europa y multi sus multimillonarios
ingresos
nace la super liga europea de fútbol una
competición creada y gobernada por 12 de
los clubes más importantes de toda
europa a los que esperan que se unan
otros tres miembros fundadores de cara
al futuro los clubes fundadores esperan
mantener conversaciones con la uefa y la
fifa buscando las mejores soluciones
para la superliga y para el conjunto del
fútbol mundial
florentino pérez presidente del real
madrid será el primer líder de esta
nueva liga que rivalizará con la actual
champions league principal y más
importante competición de clubes
europeos los clubes fundadores alegan
motivos económicos para la creación de
esta liga que según ellos ayudarán al
fútbol en general la pandemia ha
desvelado que una visión estratégica y
un enfoque comercial son necesarias para
aumentar el valor y las ayudas en
beneficio de la pirámide del fútbol en
su conjunto la competición estará
compuesta por 20 equipos los 15
fundadores más 5 que serán invitados
anualmente en función de su rendimiento
en la temporada anterior en la primera
fase habrá dos grupos de diez los tres
mejores de cada grupo se clasificarán
para cuartos de final y los cuartos y
quintos de cada grupo
en un playoff adicional a partir de ese
momento se jugarán rondas
clasificatorias a doble partido que
acabarán con una final en campo neutral
la fifa muestra su desaprobación a una
nueva competición a la que calificó de
liga cerrada y extendida si bien se
mostró abierta al diálogo
la fifa siembre defiende la unidad en el
mundo del fútbol y pide a las partes
involucradas en esta discusión acalorada
a que participan en un diálogo calmado
constructivo y balanceado por el bien
del juego y en el espíritu de la
solidaridad en el juego limpio la
competición comenzará el próximo agosto
y deberá ver a su primer campeón en mayo
un día ya supera los 15 millones de
contagios por kobe 19 mientras que la
capital nueva delhi se dirige a un
confinamiento de 6 días debido al
aumento de casos tras registrar un nuevo
récord con 273.000 810 y mil 619
fallecidos en las últimas 24 horas los
hospitales están colapsando sin camas ni
oxígeno disponible para sus pacientes
este lunes el primer ministro británico
boris johnson suspendió su visita a la
nación asiática planeada para la próxima
semana debido a la situación actual de
la pandemia
y tal como se esperaba el presidente de
cuba miguel díaz-canel fue elegido como
líder del partido comunista el cargo más
poderoso del país
de esta manera el mandatario sucederá a
raúl castro quien decidió apartarse del
cargo que ocupaba desde 2011 en
reemplazo de su hermano fidel quien
falleció en 2016 y así también termina
una era en el partido comandado por los
castros desde la revolución de 1959 y se
da paso a una generación más joven y
edificar hasta ahora avanzan los
argumentos finales en el juicio contra
el derecho bin el ex policía acusado de
homicidio en el caso de la muerte del
afroamericano georges lloyd los jurados
escucharán los últimos alegatos de la
fiscalía y la defensa sobre lo ocurrido
aquel 25 de mayo de 2020 y luego se
aislarán para tomar una decisión sólo
por el cargo de asesinato en segundo
grado chauvín podría enfrentar hasta 40
años de prisión aunque de las pautas de
sentencia del estado de minnesota
piden una sentencia más corta de hasta
15 años para alguien sin condenas
previas como el ex policía y nuestro
round
el helicóptero ingeniería mars de la
masa ha completado el primer vuelo
controlado en otro planeta una histórica
hazaña que fue recibida con aplausos por
el equipo de the jay piernas a
laboratorio de propulsión a chorro
encargado de controlar la misión desde
california el ingeniero no lleva a
ningún instrumento científico sino que
es una demostración tecnológica que
podría ayudar a adquirir conocimiento y
experiencia para futuras misiones
marinas artiñano se amplía
fueron tan sólo 40 segundos de vuelo
marciano el pequeño helicóptero
ingenuity despegó con éxito desde la
superficie del planeta rojo flotando en
el aire a unos 3 metros de altitud antes
de descender y aterrizar sobre el cráter
pero en marte una noticia que fue
recibida con vítores desde el centro de
control en california disminuir informa
que ha realizado el giro el despegue el
ascenso el vuelo estacionario el
descenso el aterrizaje los datos del
altímetro confirman que el ingeniero ha
realizado su primer vuelo de una
aeronave con motor en otro planeta el
helicóptero de propulsión solar hizo
historia al ser el primer vuelo con
motor controlado en otro planeta pero
tal hazaña no podría haberse hecho sin
su compañero en marte el rover percibir
que facilitó la comunicación con el
equipo de misión en la tierra debido a
los casi 300 millones de kilómetros que
separan ambos planetas la nave fue
diseñada para ejecutar instrucciones de
forma autónoma
tenemos tres objetivos que están en
línea con los objetivos de la agencia de
la nasa el primero es demostrar aquí en
la tierra que es posible realizar un
vuelo con motor
en la fina atmósfera de marte y ya lo
hemos hecho el mismo engineer y envió
una secuencia de imágenes mostrando su
propia sombra proyectada sobre la
superficie y el verse viviente también
captó un vídeo de la cabeza
el éxito de este debut podría llenar el
camino para nuevos modos de exploración
en marte y otros destinos del sistema
solar
mexport también abre la puerta a la
exploración humana y el helicóptero
puede entrar en zonas que el rover no
puede
hay muchas cuevas y el rover tiene que
superar muchos obstáculos en el suelo
que idealmente el helicóptero puede
sortear por eso es una gran opción poner
un vehículo aéreo en otro planeta
puede después de un gélido vuelo el
ingenuity tendrá un día de descanso para
recargarse usando un panel solar antes
de volver a volar en los próximos días
el próximo jueves el astronauta francés
thomas pesquet viajará hacia la estación
espacial internacional por esto durante
toda la semana france24 les propone una
serie de reportajes llamada thomas
pesquet viaje a las estrellas para
gravitar alrededor del viaje del
astronauta galo hoy en el primer
episodio veremos la historia del espacio
de la estación espacial internacional su
interés científico y la vertiente
política de su creación
hoy está totalmente dedicada a la
investigación científica pero en el
momento de su creación la estación
espacial internacional también fue un
instrumento político la idea surgió en
1984 y a principios de los 90 el
proyecto estaba en punto muerto todo
cambió en diciembre de 1991 la unión
soviética colapsó y abandonó su programa
espacial muchos ingenieros especialistas
en misiles quedaron desempleados en
avión cierto miedo por parte de rusia de
que se filtrarán sus habilidades sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta que en ese
momento estaba en una situación
económica muy difícil fue una fase un
poco complicada no sé si el objetivo era
recuperar a personal ganar habilidades
sí seguro gracias al talento ruso el
proyecto de la estación espacial
internacional resucitó en 1993 se firmó
un acuerdo de cooperación que la
convirtió en el escenario de unión de
los viejos enemigos el ensamblaje de
esta gigante maquinaria empezó el 20 de
noviembre de 1998 a 400 kilómetros de
altura se amarraron 15 módulos con una
capacidad de 900 metros cúbicos 400 de
ellos inhabitables
junto con 2.500 metros cuadrados de
paneles solares un laboratorio de más de
400 toneladas
un campo de fútbol que se convirtió en
el mayor objeto artificial en órbita la
estación vuela 27 mil 600 kilómetros
hora por encima de nuestras cabezas y
una velocidad que evita que caiga sobre
la tierra y que permite a los
astronautas desafiar la gravedad cada
agencia posee una parte de la estación
en función de su aporte en el marco de
un estricto sistema de intercambio somos
copropietarios así que hay que saber
compartir los gastos de la estación
hacemos lo que llamamos barter es decir
efectivamente trueques desarrollamos
material o capacidades de abastecimiento
y pagamos así de algún modo nuestro
alquiler por esta vía estuviera así
durante varios años europa ha pagado su
alquiler el desarrollo de un vehículo
para fletar cargas y la financiación de
la cúpula de observación cupola permitió
obtener transportes gratuitos de la nasa
hace más de 20 años que la estación está
ocupada de forma permanente y así está
previsto que continúe al menos por una
década su utilización acaba de ser
prolongada hasta 2030 y antes de
despedirnos los invitamos a visitar
nuestra página web www france24 puntocom
en portada detalles de la noticia sobre
el nombramiento del presidente de cuba
miguel díaz-canel como líder
el partido comunista y también detalles
sobre el incendio forestal que arrasa
cientos de hectáreas en ciudad del cabo
hasta aquí esta informativa en france 24
nos vemos más adelante quédense con
nosotros
[Música]